[Musique]
et c'est notre conseiller départemental
dans le canton de wittenheim qui est
notre invité pierre bock comment
allez-vous très bien bonjour vous drivez
ce canton avec votre binôme marie france
va là tout va bien une autre binôme très
bien si vous êtes contents les conseils
départementaux d'avoir une femme n'en
voudrait bien j'ai un peu le sentiment
sur toutes nos données de sensibilité
légèrement différent exact vous savez
exactement c'est roger sens très très
bien parce que ce qui prime c'est le
travail sur le terrain et c'est notre
engagement au service de la population
et ben c'est une bonne chose vachement
partir chez vous à wittenheim qui est le
coeur on pourrait dire géographiques
comme ça du département du haut rhin au
programme une petite balade en ballon on
se refuse rien une plongée dans
l'histoire de ce canton qui a été
évidemment aux traits marqués par
l'histoire minière les fameuses ndp à
mines de potasse d'alsace reportage à
daria ma vie
nous sommes perchés à 150 mètres de haut
dans un débat long du parc du petit
prince sous nos pieds le canton de
wittenheim ce qui fit la renommée de ce
territoire ne se trouve par contre ni
dans les airs sur le plancher des vaches
mais à plus de 600 mètres sous terre
pendant plus de soixante dix ans
l'exploitation des mines de potasse avec
mélanie du canton ils me regardaient
d'un numéro donc le mieux quand je suis
rentré pour la première fois en 1962 le
sort 40k mémoire vivante de cette époque
aujourd'hui révolue pauli et ses
camarades de l'association kalivie
wittelsheim transmettent aux plus jeunes
cette histoire qui a façonné la terre et
les hommes véritables octobre 1940 à 85
donc toujours un moment intense
d'émotion quand je rentre là dedans les
mines tiennent une place essentielle
dans le canton l'exploitation minière a
énormément structurer le territoire en
créant donc et puis autour de ces puits
ont été construits également des cités
minières et tout autour se sont
construits écoles églises terrain de
sport enfin vraiment toute l'activité de
la population pouvait prendre place dans
cette cité minière
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de là le carreau
rodolphe acquis par le département en
2007 il tient lui aussi une place
importante
la transmission de cette mémoire
industrielle ce site est animé par
l'association du groupe rodolphe qui
apporte une animation autour donc de la
mémoire minière en particulier en
maintenant les gros équipements qui ont
permis l'extraction de la potasse
définitivement arrêté en 2002 la
production de potasse a diminué dès les
années 70 s'est alors posé la question
de la reconversion des friches
industrielles à wittenheim les cavs ont
laissé place à d'importantes
installations commerciales comme le
décathlon village centre commercial et
parcs de loisirs sportifs qui attire un
million de visiteurs chaque année la
reconversion s'est fait en plusieurs
temps cela a commencé autour des années
1980 par la création du pôle 430 et sur
le site nous sommes précisément il
s'agit de l'installation du magasin
décathlon aujourd'hui le pôle 430 avec
le cas ligonnes qui se situe sur le banc
de kingersheim représente la plus grande
zone commerciale du département au delà
de la question de la reconversion des
espaces et industriel c'est surtout la
question de l'emploi qui préoccupent les
collectivités quand les mines de potasse
au plus fort de leur activité embauchait
près de onze mille personnes
c'était quand même un nombre d'emplois
exceptionnel il a fallu trouver et
d'autres activités le commerce a été la
première mais ce n'est pas la seule
avec 53 mégawatts de puissance maximale
ungersheim accueille la plus grande
centrale solaire d'alsace 19 hectares
installé sur l'ancien puits et
marie-louise le plus le site accueille
des entreprises installées sous les
panneaux ce genre de sites aujourd'hui
avec le six entreprises qui sont d'ores
et déjà installés sur ce parc là c'est
une cinquantaine d'emplois qui ont été
créés donc c'est une reconversion tout à
fait intéressante d'une friche qui
malgré tout il faut le rappeler permet
de ne pas consommer des espaces
agricoles
lieuse développement l'entreprise
exploitante a d'ores et déjà obtenu
l'autorisation d'agrandir le site plus
de cent ans après l'ouverture de la
première mine le bassin minier fait une
entrée fracassante dans le domaine des
énergies renouvelables
on avait très très belle image pierre
bock tu es notre invité on l'a vu dans
le reportage comment les mines
finalement au façonner la terre et les
hommes est ce que c'est cette transition
de l'art et des mines finalement a été
difficile à gérer pour les élus et les
habitants ça a été difficile mais faut
pas oublier que les mines ont fait la
richesse de ce territoire et les
richesses de la dia soir de notre pays
les mines c'était une véritable saga
industrielle c est en fait une création
de
comment je pourrais appeler ça
c'est ce qui faisait vivre il fait vivre
qui fait vivre l'ensemble d'un
territoire et qui naturellement a
beaucoup moules et les territoires
puisque c'étaient des mines qui étaient
des mines des villes des communes
rurales et c'est quoi nourrir à l'hôte
évolué au rythme de la mine avec un
remodelage du paysage puisque on a créé
des pikmin 24 puits de mine on a créé
des on a créé des chevalements on a créé
des terrils on a créé des cités minières
justement vous avez aussi créé des
emplois ça représentait un revenu
d'emploi est ce qu'aujourd'hui on vient
pour lui laisse a représenté 13 1880
emplois dans les années 1948 c'était
vraiment votre email ce niveau d'emploi
non non on n'a pas retrouvé il ya un
déficit au niveau des emplois
naturellement et malgré les
recommandations du plan cadre qui s'est
fait qui a été signé en 1996 où
l'état les fonds européens lait collecté
beaucoup contribué valérie ça on n'est
pas encore arrivé à se combler ce
déficit des enfants et parcourez en
revanche vous développez bien puisqu'il
ya aussi le parc du petit prince
maintenant j'ai demandé à si ça marchait
ça commence à bien faire elle part du
petit prince qui à l'écomusée d'alsace
est-ce que les loisirs c'est maintenant
aujourd'hui on va dire une place un peu
important dans l'économie du territoire
c'est important on sait bien que le
tourisme est très important au niveau
économique dans ce secteur entre colmar
et mulhouse ya pas il n'y a pas de date
unités touristiques très importante et
donc c'est important pour l'attractivité
de ce territoire de ce bassin et le
département s'implique fortement dans la
synergie de l'ensemble des trois sites
puisqu'on un carreau rodolphe on à
l'écomusée et on a
part du petit train ce fait c'est un
voyage dans le temps et dans l'espace ça
puisque vous parlez du carreau rodolphe
juste à côté du parc et des communes il
ya ce cas fameux carreau rodolphe que
j'ai visités qui est tout à fait
étonnant est ce qu'aujourd'hui à une
réflexion qui est engagée pour valoriser
ce site ans aujourd'hui pour l'instant
naturellement il ya un groupe de
réflexion qui se penche sur ce site ces
sites est encore n'est pas totalement
ouvert au public parce que il faut au
niveau de sécurité il ya encore beaucoup
de choses à faire mais pour l'instant il
faut maintenir ce site et qui en fait
qui représentent nos racines voilà et à
côté de ces sites on a on a notre site
important de l'écomusée qui est très
connu qui est vivant c'est ce qui est
important d'europe et qui existe depuis
30 ans et les sit in écomusée reprendre
représente la terre symbole de la terre
avec tout ce qui touche à la tradition
la culture alsacienne à l'âme alsacienne
les maisons alsaciennes izon gironde
architecture les métiers d'antan et à
côté de ça naturellement nous avons
notre symbole des symboles des airs avec
le parc donc du petit prince le
repreneur il s'appelle les périls et
voilà ces trois entités se complètent à
merveille à nous verser d'une guerre
petite question il nous reste le caron
secondes lorsque vous pouvez vous agir
vous collectivité vous impulseur de tout
cela pour améliorer l'attractivité au
jour de ce bassin minier alors là très
vite et c'est un tout les communes n'ont
pas attendu
la fin des mines ont déjà commencé à à
remodeler certains paysages parce que
certaines certaines friches
industrielles qu'on a qu'on a remodelé
pour soir nature et soit soit des
friches industrielles qui ont été re on
a créé des espaces naturels aujourd'hui
elle ne passe par attirer le tourisme
mais voilà on a une réserve naturelle
régionale leur osmose qui qui
représentera une sur 146 ha tu n'es pas
rien et qui avait que plus de 300
espèces de flore et plus de cent
soixante dix espèces d'animaux et ben on
a été ravi de se balader à wittenheim
dans votre canton